time now for the press preview the first
look at the front pages
uh tonight's in the next half an hour
we'll be taking a look at what's making
the headlines
uh with this pair the financial times
white hall editor sebastian payne
and the senior editor at the economist
anne mckelvoy
guys lovely to have you on the program
this evening and guess what
plenty to talk about i i suppose we
should start
after we've had a look at the paper
stack thank you for reminding me guys
the debt with the daily telegraph
carrying accusations from downing street
sources
the borough johnson's former chief
adviser dominick cummings leaked private
tax from the prime minister
concerning lobbying to the media uh
let's have a look at the ft
they have word uh the former pm david
cameron lobbied the top civil servant at
the treasury
and indeed the deputy governor at the
bank of england on behalf
of green sold capital
at the guardian well it's choosing to
take the angle that mr cameron asked the
bank of england and the treasury to risk
up to 20 billion pounds in taxpayer cash
to help green seal capital at the start
of the global pandemic
uh same story in the eye it says new
emails have surfaced
showing that mr cameron chased the top
officials
to help his client and the metro
uh choosing a different story leading
with the us president joe biden
calling on fellow world leaders to do
their part to tackle climate change he
pledged
to have america's greenhouse gas
emissions by 2030.
the mail meanwhile juxtaposing a
thousand fans being allowed into the
world snooker finals as part of a trial
and covered safety well they're
contrasting that with the fact that
there is still
a 30 person limit on attendance at
funerals
has the feel that that might be changing
sometime soon uh as we said
joined tonight by sebastian and then and
good to see you guys and we can
crack on with the stories and and and to
you first
um a story in fact which i think is
going to eventually end up appearing in
pretty much all the papers first
editions perhaps
the sun which we don't have just yet but
the daily telegraph
oh it seems we might have a name uh for
the man responsible or the person
responsible for leaking the tax
yes indeed and that's of course dominic
cummings
who left number 10 after a big bust up
with the prime minister and with
others on the team there that was before
christmas
this has been around i would say in
shouts and murmurs in westminster for
some time the allegation and it is still
only an allegation the dominic cummings
leaked private texts from the prime
minister to which he had access
and that so say allies of the prime
minister and there is a senior
official there number 10 quoted in the
piece that explains
why we've had something of a flurry of
embarrassing stories about boris
johnson's
texts uh whether it be with james dyson
over
lobbying for his company as a in terms
of
tax treatment if he were to help on
providing ventilators in the pandemic
or on other associations of boris
johnson including with muhammad bill
salman
in saudi arabia these were clearly not
things the prime minister particularly
wanted
to come out or to come out in that way
and the surmise in the telegraph's piece
and elsewhere is that this is a grudge
match it's basically
a revenge you talk about in opera the
gutter damn wrong well this would be i
suppose it would be the gutter doming
but it's either way it's the final
flourish of dominic cummings's revenge
um sebastian of course clearly
allegations of corruption
allegations of cronyism you know this is
bread and butter to political
journalists and
and rightly so but but the source of the
leaks i mean is that going to be raising
any eyebrows outside of sw1 or is it as
my colleague john craig likes to say one
for the aficionados
i think it's a bit of both now and like
the fact is obviously this stuff that's
made its way into the public domain
is very embarrassing for boris johnson
you know those texts with
mohamed bin salman the text with james
dyson
this is not the sort of way we see
government operating in this country
people
sending whatsapp messages to do things
that would normally go through official
channels
and obviously there's been a stream of
this stuff there's been several leak
inquiries i've actually lost count of
who's doing what at the moment but
clearly people inside number 10 and this
story appears in several newspapers i
think it's in the times
and in the sun as well suggests that
senior people
near to boys johnson are a bit fed up
with all this stuff getting into the
public domain
and have decided that they think mr
cummings is the suspect we should point
out
mr cummings hasn't responded to this
there's no comment from him
on this now but i think it will raise
eyebrows and mc dominic cummings does
have a profile beyond westminster as
well
people who've seen the brexit movie will
know him as the chief strategist
behind the leave campaign and he
developed sort of infamy
during the time that he was inside there
but there is a lot of
acrimony still about his departure and
if mr cummings is guilty of leaking
these text messages as is being alleged
then you can imagine there will be
another salvo from him if
in the coming days so i think this war
has really just intensified
and if it's been damaging for the prime
minister so far then there may well be
more to come
and take us to the to the front of the
ft and and their story of course i mean
uh
sebastian was saying that there are a
number of probes that the ft identifies
eight of them
in their leading article but what we've
learned as the day has gone on is the
the efforts of the scale of the effort
that david cameron went to in reaching
out and contacting not just ministers
you know but some very significant and
senior public officials
i think it's the intensity of the
lobbying isn't it it's clear that mr
cameron was certainly trying to do
a job that would make him good value for
green sill and for that company and that
he was entitled
to make his living after he was prime
minister you can argue about whether the
rules are sensibly
drawn up for that sort of thing but i
think where you get to a judgment
question in the
uh ft story today is is right on this
point
is the insistent lobbying of treasury
officials i think come out of this
quite well reading into the ft story is
that
they seem to kind of hold him off really
they block him and
they have that nice civil service way of
saying
this former prime minister is in has
some advisory role
slightly dismissively but this advisory
role clearly meant that he was
tapping up very insistently officials
who'd worked for him directly
and i think the manner of doing that and
particularly the way the story has
spread also to the bank of england who
would not be
happy about this at all of course people
will use their
contacts and we shouldn't be unrealistic
about this people
do use their contacts and these days
they tend to reach out through texts or
through whatsapp they're not going to
send a handwritten letter or carrier
pigeon but it is the scale at which
david cameron was doing it
and it could be seen as putting some
degree of moral pressure
on people who worked for him as prime
minister that's going to be very awkward
for him
i mean sebastian when i heard i had one
cabinet mr i think it was quasi quantum
but i i i will check that but you're
seeing
on on television today look it's
entirely to be expected
you know in fact it is a good thing that
people can have direct access
to senior ministers and prime ministers
but i suppose
the problem with that is that we don't
all have that access
that no one enjoys the access uh that
certain individuals do dependent of
course on the administration and indeed
the prime minister
well to use a phrase to appoint lord
copper with that that yes it is right
that
people in the private sector should have
access to ministers and it's not healthy
for government to have
business and the civil service operating
in a hermetically sealed bubble as often
has happened
in the past there but ann is exactly
right this lobbying was going on at the
absolute peak of the coronavirus crisis
where ministers
like rishi sunak and andrew bailey the
bank of england governor
were trying to keep the whole british
economy on the road at this point and
they came up with these
schemes to get money out to small and
medium-sized businesses
as soon as possible that was a very
complex task and you know
the economic turmoil of the past years
unlike anything
that we've seen in decades if not longer
than that
in britain's modern history and i think
that's the thing that really surprised
me about these communications
the treasury made it quite clear early
on the green cell capital was not going
to be allowed into these schemes and yet
mr cameron and mr green still according
to these communiques
kept on communicating and pushing to
different ministers and different
officials trying to make the case for
their products
that's fine that you know mr cameron's
no longer in politics he's got a job
in the private sector he can do that but
i think there is just that question of
was it a sensible and wise thing to do
and also david cameron would have known
the pressure he was putting on these
individuals you know
john glenn who's the exchequer secretary
to the treasury who was in these
these papers released today he's been a
big role of trying to get these schemes
working there
and i'm sure he didn't appreciate shall
we say that extra pressure from david
cameron and there's one of the officials
who actually said
we've got incoming from our old boss
here which i think gives you a bit of a
hint
of the atmosphere inside the treasury
having to deal with mr cameron's
requests
well and just as we as we showed that
our viewers looking at the lead article
in the dark
the guardian again talking about david
cameron pushing pushing the bank of
england and all of this i mean this is
where the point that both of you were
making and agreeing with it
that sebastian was making and you were
nodding an agreement i just david
cameron has worked in the back room of
politics he's worked in the front room
of politics he's been prime minister
did he not expect that at some point
some of this detail might make its way
into the public domain
including that figure on the front of
the guardian 20 billion pounds we're
talking about
well i suppose he could simply have
calculated that greensville capital
wouldn't go so spectacularly boston
which is the
reason that so much of this has come out
uh
politicians in their afterlife make
calculations don't they about who they
they think they should work for it was a
spectacular miscalculation of course
others were also wrong about queensville
capital that's certainly the case it's
not only david cameron who's been
caught out on on that one so i don't
know that he would have thought they
would come out
and also remember if green cell had been
prospering
and if its products had been doing well
well you could say he would have said
well you see this goes to show i was
actually lobbying something which i
really believe in i did choose to go
work for this company because i believe
in its products
it's the fact that when it all goes
wrong and this is the story of
the link between bankruptcies finance
and politics
back to the novels of anthony trollope
it's all there in the the 19th century
of bubbles and busts you're caught on
the wrong side of them then everything
comes out in the least
flattering light i think personally that
the decision
to extend that lobbying to the bank of
england in terms of
that kind of bailout money that really
for me does
take it to another dimension i think the
treasury is well capable of looking
after itself as it
it showed it was an irritation he
crossed the line but
i'm not that surprised by it i think it
just
is a bit more of a misjudgment to get
involved with the bank of england and
that is really where you're
putting yourself i think in a very
vulnerable position in terms of
your own judgment and also these are
people who know how to
fight back and they are going to say no
and you know they
really don't mind it coming out
afterwards so i think on all schools
it's been a bit of a pratfall hasn't it
you might say that i couldn't possibly
comment sorry say what you were saying
just briefly yes i was just going to pop
in there and say i think what happened
here
david cameron made a bet with green cell
captor and don't forget that
this banker was very closely tied into
or he was brought into the civil service
by lord haywood the former head of the
civil service
and so you can understand why mr cameron
would have thought this was a good
and sure way to earn a living once he'd
finished
leaving government here but you know
i've spoken to ministers who worked
closely with david cameron while he was
in government
and they acknowledged that simply he
just made a very bad call because many
former prime ministers like john major
or gordon brown
they do much more low-key things a
couple of speeches here a book
there a turn on sky news on the sunday
morning programs
they don't do these big grand things
that of high risk and high reward
and i think really it must say something
about mr cameron's character that he
left
government he left parliament and he
decided to make this risk and when you
look at those emails today
it actually feels a little bit desperate
in some respects that
cameron was continuing to push these
emails and push green sales products on
the civil service because it was made
quite clear early on that rishi sunak
was not willing
to engage with them and as an said you
know you've spoken to the treasury they
said no
you then go to the bank of england and
try and reach the governor
he also says no and at some point
obviously you have to realize that it's
just not going to happen i think
he maybe just went a little bit too far
there seb and paul's right there we'll
talk about that topic i'm sure again
next uh uh but after the break
uh it may not seem like it but
apparently britain is no longer in a
pandemic we'll dig into the science
behind matt glenn when we come back
welcome back to the press preview
sebastian and still with us um
and let's return to the front page of
the of the telegraph anne
and the story there britain no longer in
a pandemic
household well this
obviously depends a bit on the
definition of a pandemic but it really
is a reflection of the fact that a high
vaccination rate
and obviously a much lower r infection
rate
means that britain technically now
escapes the definition of a pandemic
whereas of course lots of other european
countries were still struggling with
their our rate and their vaccination
rate would
still count as being in the pandemic it
doesn't mean
that the behaviors that we had before
the pandemic can simply
spring back into life and it doesn't
mean of course that something couldn't
go wrong
but yes we do on the most of the
uh definitions that you would apply to
the numbers britain
is out of it at least across fingers
it's out of it for now
yep fingers toes everything else crossed
um sebastian
i do want to have a quick look at the at
the metro front page because it's a
significant
announcement one which we were expecting
from president biden but to half
u.s greenhouse gases by by 2030.
the question as always isn't it is
whether or not anyone else is going to
do the same if you don't have the rest
of the world with you
what's the point
sebastian to you
i think and we'll talk to you instead
why don't you have a good
i'm sure he'll be materialized yeah
indeed i mean but
the interesting thing president biden
has really set out this is
his first major international summit as
the new president
he clearly wants to see himself as being
the presidency that's going to
to tackle climate change looks like
you've got sebastian back as well
you know what we've got 20 seconds
sebastian so tell us just how excited
you are about president biden
nope nope i i know i recognize that
blank stare and i recognize that blank
stare and just you finishes off
i was only going to say yes it's
obviously only not even half the battle
but when america gives that kind of lead
i think the assumption is a lot of
western countries will fall in behind it
you can see that happening in britain on
the road
to the cop 26 uh climate summit it's
also i think
really intended to be an offer to china
and to russia to other countries and
maybe
not haven't been so bothered about their
international reputation
to to match this and that's really the
diplomatic game